well one thing to feel punchy about the
ins and outs of the nfl's new replay
review expansion that applies to
offensive and defensive pass
interference that was the big story in
arizona it was a rule that got thrown
together in a day rich mckay the
chairperson to the competition committee
said we made sausage in a day which
probably isn't the best way to be making
rules because they didn't anticipate the
competition committee didn't anticipate
what kind of pushback they were going to
get from the coaches from the owners and
had to slap this thing together so
knowing what we know now big cat and
there are plenty of questions that still
need to be answered but the blanket
notion that offensive and defensive pass
interference will be as reviewable as
any other thing that can be reviewed
challenge flag during the normal course
of events automatic replay review after
turnovers and touchdowns automatic
replay review in the final two minutes
of either half or overtime what was your
reaction to the news that the nfl is now
crossing this boundary of making pass
interference both offensive and
defensive subject to replay review
i hate it it's an overreaction and the
blood is on your hands mike florio
because you
were asking for this we had to take
discussion we had this discussion right
after the saints rams when everyone was
overreacting including you and i said
calm down it happens once every however
many years it's never happened that type
of blown call has never really happened
in the nfl to that extent at that stage
let's not create an entirely new rule
more replays and you know what mike what
i really hate you're throwing a flag on
the field so basically plays that don't
have flags you get to add a flag and now
you can find it on any play where does
it stop you can find holding on any play
you can find past interference on any
play
this is
this is not going to work out like i
don't want this what i want is a simple
mechanism as you say where they can
basically have someone sitting in new
york city and stop the game if something
egregious happens which happens one in a
million plays that's what we need we
don't need the ability for coaches to
throw flags add flags to the field more
replays
offensive pass interferences is or
defensive pass interference they're
subjective when you slow it down it
makes it look like everything is past
interference i hate hate hate this new
rule mike and look i i wanted change but
this is not the change i wanted i wanted
the sky judge i wanted the extra
official who is in the booth watching
all of the camera angles that we see at
home bridging the gap between what the
officials who are out there on the field
trying number one to stay alive and not
get trampled bridging the gap between
what they see in real time with the
naked eye and what the rest of us see at
home and and if you have that official
in the booth that's when you can buzz
the referee and say drop a flag pick up
a flag do this and it doesn't require
the game to be stopped it's no different
than that quick caucus that we'll see on
the field where a couple of officials
talk to each other that would have been
a much better solution because that's
your break glass in event of emergency
option where you've got one person who
oversees everything that's happening on
the field and that person is a member of
the officiating crew just with a
different perspective than what the
other officials have i don't like the
idea that this replay review is going to
be applied for all offensive and
defensive pass interference i felt like
they had to do something but this isn't
the ideal solution and they're going to
find out it's not the ideal solution
when there's a pick play that's that's
called routinely when offensive pass
interference is called more often when
we see offsetting offensive and
defensive pass interference that we
never see now but i think that's going
to become a crutch for al river on just
hey let's just do the whole thing over
again there's a little pushing by the
receiver there's a little pushing by the
defensive back let's just call it
offsetting fouls and do it all over
again i think that's a possibility so
you know they worry about unintended
consequences when they just want to not
deal with change this is a situation
where they should have been worried
about unintended consequences because
there could be several of them
everything you said just rings so hollow
because you
wanted this i want this guy judge
mike you wanted this and i said it they
should have realized a bad idea when i
said it it was a bad idea because guess
what more than anything i speak as the
most regular common fan out there and
what i don't want is more stoppage more
replays more sitting there and going
over every single angle and saying yeah
is it this is it that more i don't know
jim i don't want that in the game right
so
they screw they screwed this thing up
and
they're gonna find out real quickly it's
gonna be i think similar to the rule the
new you know the new rules that they
made last year where they started
throwing flags a lot more on hits over
the middle during uh training camp in
pre-season and they adjusted to it in
the regular season i don't know how you
adjust this but i don't want to watch a
million replays of past interference
here's the thing i think what the
average fan wants is a mechanism for
quickly fixing an egregious error like
that that's why the sky judge concept
makes sense and really what they could
have done and this happens from time to
time where al riveron uses that pipeline
from the league office in ways that he
shouldn't telling someone to throw a
flag he could have avoided this entire
mess by simply telling the referee in
that game throw a flag there was an
egregious and blatant pass interference
even though you're not supposed to use
it that way let's fix this thing before
it becomes a mess that takes over the
entire game i think that the average fan
would prefer to have clear mistakes that
we all agree on the old 50 drunks in a
bar standard that mike holmgren coined
when they started replay review if it's
obvious it's a mistake fix it you don't
need to have replay review for every
touchdown to make sure there wasn't a
pick a block more than a yard behind the
line of scrimmage that there wasn't a
push off that there wasn't a subtle
shove here or there and slow the game
down that way i want a fail safe for the
egregious where we all see it and we all
know it's a problem that's what i want
and i think after a year of of what they
put in place they're going to wish that
that's what they had done here's the
other problem i have with this i
the league you know the scoring the
offensive nature of the league has all
been great it's it's obviously like you
know young quarterbacks and look at what
patrick mahomes is doing to the afc west
and what he's going to do for the afc
for the next decade and kind of
invigorate all the football there
quarterback it's a quarterback driven
league but at some point you have to
give the defense a chance and this is
just another thing and i know they say
they can call it both ways right they
can call offensive past interference
defensive pass interference which one do
you think is going to get thrown more
it's definitely going to be the
defensive pass interference and i think
it's just another thing that puts the
defensive units behind the eight ball
and defense becomes harder and harder to
play in the nfl year in and year out
these guys have to think too much they
can't play football and it's going to be
more points and and defense is not going
to matter as much yeah i disagree with
you on that we crunched the numbers
yesterday and and i'm going to get the
decimals wrong because i don't remember
them specifically but the average
defensive pass interference calls per
team last year were 7.6
i believe offensive pass interference
was less than three per team
i think we're going to have more
offensive pass interference called by
replay review that's where this door is
going to swing in favor of the defenses
because right now you don't see as much
offensive pass interference as defensive
but you and i both know what happens
it's going to get called more especially
the pick plays because you know we can
talk about the standard for uh
indisputable visual evidence clear and
obvious whatever but the pick play is
going to be obvious if there is blocking
happening by an eligible receiver more
than one yard away from the line of
scrimmage before the ball is thrown
that's going to be clear and obvious and
that's going to be easy to call and
every touchdown every passing touchdown
is going to require al riveron to look
and see if there was a pick because it's
going to be obvious it's going to be
clear and the touchdown is going to get
wiped off the board if there was any
blocking more than one yard beyond the
line of scrimmage blame yourself mike
florio i did not
you did this to america
you did it i'm the one who said this is
a bad idea
but you didn't have any reasons other
than it was a bad idea see now that all
happened we can say what about cat
uncatchable balls what about pick plays
what about offensive pass interference i
didn't want it for offensive pass
interference i only wanted it for
defensive pass interference all right
let me ask you one last question about
this because i was reading an article
about it this morning uh doing my
research no big deal but
it seemed like and you were down there
in arizona
they rushed this thing through because
they just had to react because sean
payton has really made this his cause
and he's rallied a bunch of coaches
behind it
it felt like they rushed this through
and they didn't do a lot of thinking and
from everything i read they were just
trying to get out of there they were
just all trying to get out of there on
tuesday night and not be in arizona
anymore so they basically said you know
what let's do something it's it you know
you can notice this by the fact that
it's a one-year uh trial period rule so
that makes it even worse in my mind the
fact that it was clearly rushed it
wasn't thought out they just wanted to
get out of the building this is
you know the the owners and and the
coaches this is going to be a future
them problem when they get to the middle
of the of the season and they're losing
games or games are slowing down and they
lose momentum and all these things
happen and fans are complaining it's
going to be the fact that they rushed
this decision and mike florio those are
the two people i'm blaming this is the
old uh jury reaches a verdict at five
o'clock on a friday afternoon let's just
get the hell out of here and go home and
get this over with i don't disagree with
that but here's who i blame i blame rich
mckay
because they wanted to cram through
basically no change or minimal change
and they didn't properly read the room
they didn't understand in advance where
the coaches were going to come down on
this where the owners were going to come
down they were so caught up in their
bubble of we don't need to do anything
they didn't bother to think what was
going to happen when they got to arizona
and the coaches revolted and the owners
said we have to do something that i
think is what is is uh important to keep
in mind you have to know if you remember
the competition committee you have to
know which way the wind's blowing and
they what they try to do is they try to
create the wind and that's where they
screw up you can't create the wind as
the competition committee the wind is
still blowing beyond your meeting room
and if you don't know it before you get
to the site of the league meeting you're
destined to have an outcome like this so
they did a bad job of understanding how
how strongly the desire was for change
and then they had to throw something
together mckay said it himself we made
sausage in a day that's not a way to fix
this problem that's bad sausage and and
i like sean payton i think sean payton's
a fantastic coach i you know i think
he's good for the league in general but
this is one of those situations someone
had to stand up and just give sean
payton a hug and be like listen man
but whatever rules coming here
it's not going to bring your team back
the saints are not coming back this year
they're not going to play in the super
bowl we it's over it's done here take a
hug it's not your fault sean payton
they're never coming back and just and
like i feel like he needs that because
he's kind of chasing something that's
never coming back he's chasing his own
shadow
there's a weird dynamic within the nfl
that when a team gets burned by a really
bad rule that team is against changing
the rule because they think that they're
going to benefit from it at some point
down the road that there's some weird
football karma out there that's going to
help them
later so i admire sean payton for saying
we can't have this i mean you can't have
these games decided by mistakes made by
officials and you know big cat i've
heard that you like to gamble a little
bit as legalized gambling spreads
throughout the country if the nfl
doesn't fix these flaws that's when
they're going to have congress up their
butts that's what they need to be
concerned about they can't have these
defects in officiating i just don't like
the fact that they fought against it for
months and then they threw something
together when they realized there was no
way to get out of arizona with no change
we got to take a break when we return
we've got some questions from you that
we will be answering i have a feeling
one or two might have something to do
with replay more pft live coming at you
right after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports